good morning good afternoon or good
evening depending on where you are in
the world
i'm chris down i'm a kernel engineer at
facebook i work on
memory management mostly in the area of
control groups or c groups which are one
of the building blocks for modern linux
containers
i'm also a maintainer of the systemd
project
small project which some of you may have
heard of and or wrote an angry post
about
in general like my my job is thinking
about how can we help
make linux operate more efficiently and
more scalably
um it's quite important because at
facebook you know now we have a million
plus machines
we can't just buy more ram we can't just
in throw hardware at
all of our problems we need to extract
the absolute maximum out of each machine
safely so that's one of the things which
i'm going to be talking about today
i know that nobody really gives a single
thoughts about that though what they
really care about is that i was arched
linux user since 2008
so i remember the bad old days of
inscripts and all kinds of stuff
so yeah nobody can [ __ ] me telling
me those days were better
um especially as someone who works on
upstream software who works on quite
core software
you know i i find arsenal that's
incredibly useful
having uh the latest course offer
available having a great build system
all of that
makes art really for me the perfect
distribution for anyone who works on
kernel for anyone who works on systemd
for anyone who works on like upstream
software
it's a great distribution if you were a
developer and you work on those kind of
things so keeping recent keeping rolling
makes creation of testing of new
features and fixes really really
straightforward so i
i definitely give like a big thumbs up
for arch linux and that's one of the
reasons i've been using it for so long
so thank you very much to everyone who's
been involved in it
so memory management in general is the
kind of topic which i want to talk to
you about today i want to help give you
more of the tools and information which
you need to manage memory at scale
there are many many misconceptions even
among senior members of our community
about the primitives which we provide as
the kernel and what they are good
and what they are not good for and
memory management in general is a very
inexact science
where basically everything is a
trade-off between performance
or accuracy and it's not a
mathematically
correct science you've really got to
trade off so i want to give you a better
feeling about what tradeoffs and what
decisions might be applicable to you and
your workloads and hopefully
you'll come out of this talk with some
ideas that you might want to take away
and apply
as part of your memory management
strategy and help make it more efficient
or more reliable for your specific case
first before we even go into that let's
cast our minds back a few years to 2017
and the years before the big rona hit us
and left me
uh straight stranded trying to record
this in my own house
uh with the kitten behind me um so i
went to a number of conferences that
year talking about cgroup v2 and secret
b2 is our big bet as an industry
for resource control and management in
the linux kernel c groups are
essentially a kernel mechanism which
we're building to balance
and limit and throttle things like
memory
memory cpu and io and that kind of stuff
things which you share across a system
and across
applications we have pretty good
problems at facebook you know our user
base is increasing
our product range is diversifying but
with that growth
comes scaling problems of a class which
we've never really had to deal with
before
and in the next few years we're really
going to feel this crunch for capacity
and we simply can't effectively solve
this problem by throwing
more and more hardware at the problem
not only because of expense but because
of availability it's it's really
starting to become a problem and you
know we have hundreds of thousands of
machines we just cannot afford to waste
capacity
a small loss on every machine is
translates to a huge absolute loss
across the fleet so we need to use
resources more efficiently
and secrets are one of the things which
fundamentally allow us to do that
this is also really important as many
huge site outages and incidents are
caused by
resource control issues not being able
to readily control things like cpu
memory
io it can really either cause or make
worse existing issues and we've seen
this not only at facebook but
a lot of our competitors like google
amazon linkedin all of those kind of
uh companies you know we are having a
lot of problems as an industry dealing
with these resource control problems so
we need to start
an initiative industry-wide to solve
this
problem and that's a large reason why c
groups by their nature
exist
two years ago it was a totally different
story though uh we had really only one
user of c groups which was us even
google which is now a fairly large user
hadn't really started
using them at that point and it took a
lot of work and overcoming obstacles to
reach the point where we are confident
saying you know these these are now
ready for use in production generically
in general in the old days what happened
was we had a whole bunch of cool and new
primitives which we'd invented which we
were very excited to use and seemed
correct
but when we actually went to go and use
them it ended up being
something kind of like this instead um
the primitives aren't really wrong
uh the problem is just that they're kind
of on the right track
but we need to know in which cases we
should make the primitives
or the operating system a little bit
more square and the primitives may be a
little bit more
round to achieve what we want and
knowing which of these makes sense in
each situation requires a huge amount of
testing and experimentation
another problem in general is that
limiting one resource artificially
can if you're not careful just result in
transferring all of its contention
onto another resource for example if you
limit
memory too tightly for an application
then it likely will just become
a huge amount of disk io which is
obviously not desirable
this is because we will start doing
things like evicting the page cache
and might also start the swap pages
which are harder or more in use than we
would ideally like to swap
and as such we need an underlying system
which mitigates these issues
and we simply didn't have that back in
2017.
this is also why you'll see me talking a
number of times in the talk
about io uh you might wonder why is he
talking about i o when we're
overall kind of talking about memory um
the reason is because
without talking about io we can only
really have an academic
discussion of limiting memory so to be
practically useful
you always have to have controls on i o
when talking about controlling memory
for the reason we mentioned just before
about like evicting page cache
swapping out that kind of stuff
another problem is that while we have
had serie 2 technically
working for a while the past few years
the major focus has been on issues which
it has
brought up elsewhere because secret v2
limits resources in a way that was never
really done before in the colonel
it has exposed a lot of these issues
these long-standing issues they're not
new issues but we've never really had
fine-grained prioritization
so they've never clearly been exposed in
such a way before
and there's not enough time in these 45
minutes to really go over every single
issue which we found
but i did go into them quite in detail
at my talk in
sr recon last year if you go for me at
sri con 2019
you'll probably find a lot more detail
about the problems we had with the xt4
with journaling
uh with uh memory mapping semaphores in
the in the kernel and so on and so forth
in general like the point is we found
and fixed a humongous
number of issues across the kernel from
memory management to io to file systems
all over the place
and a huge amount of our time has really
been spent invested in
improving resource control in these
subsystems to not break down under
scrutiny
so let's kick off the main part of the
talk by discussing some of the
fundamentals of linux memory management
and this is really important to go over
at this point of the talk because if we
don't agree about these then the rest of
the talk you're just going to spend like
shaking your head so we should at least
agree what we're trying to achieve in
the first place
and one thing that's really critical in
understanding that is understanding
uh in linux linux has different concepts
of different types of memory
from the cpu's perspective they're
really kind of all the same it has some
kind of
concept of different permissions but it
doesn't know anything really about the
semantic intent of the pages
um for example in anonymous memory is as
the name would imply
not backed by any backing store memory
explicitly allocated by malek and so on
and so forth
during a program lifetime typically is
anonymous because it doesn't have
anywhere else to go
most people also know about caches and
buffers which are kind of two sides of
the same coin nowadays they're both
part of the unified page caching linux
so i'll probably just refer to them kind
of interchangeably as
far pages or unified page cache or
something like that
one of the problems is like if you ask
most linux users or most linux admins
or even more senior linux administrators
you know they will
say you know file captures and buffers
they're reclaimable they can easily be
trivially trivially freed when when
things
uh go awry and they're not entirely
wrong in that
but the problem is that people
misunderstand what reclaimable means
reclaimable doesn't mean like you can
reclaim it it means
you might be able to reclaim it if you
ask at the right time
and we happen to be feeling particularly
nice at that particular moment
so for example if some application is
absolutely hammering on some file on the
disk right
it's very unlikely that we would evict
it from the the file cache
because we would just destroy the
application performance so
while these can under some circumstances
be free trivially
it doesn't always have to be the case
and this can cause some confusion when
people ask you know
why did my application run out of memory
when i still had this
free memory um and we'll come back to
some more of these unexpected
foibles and in a little bit the fact
that these caches might not be evictable
at a particular point in time is another
example of why the resident set size or
rss
a metric that we'd love to measure is
really kind of [ __ ]
rss often unduly skews a lot of
attention towards a few
singular types of memory anonymous
memory and
mapped file memory and we forget though
that
many workloads simply cannot operate in
any performant way
without extensive file and buffer caches
or other what other system-wide shared
memory so measuring rss is kind of a
losing game
and the reason that we measure it is not
because it's
it's a good measurement the reason is
because it's really really [ __ ] easy
to measure
which is a nonsensical reason right it
doesn't make any sense like i don't
understand
why how we've got to this point so when
somebody asks how much memory your
application uses or your service users
the only reasonable answer unless you've
compressed it beyond belief and found
out the answer for yourself like using
some kind of workload compression is
that you have absolutely no clue like
how much it actually uses right
um in one case inside facebook just as
an example a team that had for years
believe their memory footprint was
in the order of like 100 to 150
megabytes
found out that it was more like two to
three gigabytes of critical
memory working set size just because of
file caches and buffers and so on and so
forth
so you really can't just exclude them
from your memory calculations if they
don't exist
because it's not a reasonable way to
operate your service or application
this is one reason why in modern
resource control and in sugary 2
we limit all types of memory together
instead of just trying to limit
anonymous memory or one type of memory
or so on and so forth the problem there
is if you limit
just anonymous memory or you do what
secret v1 did
and you know limit every type of single
memory separately
you're trivially going to allow the
application to still
cause problems on the system by
thrashing the file cache or by using
some type of pages which you're not
accounting for
so it doesn't really work very well in
the long term
this whole discussion also brings us
somewhat neatly onto swap
swap in general is a very widely
misunderstood concept highly
controversial topic
um a lot of people think that swap is
mostly irrelevant nowadays with tens of
gigabytes of memory
it's a little bit strange though because
for the things that swap is good at
you really cannot get them any other way
and for the things which is better it's
usually entirely possible to mitigate
them so usually these discussions kind
of hinge on these very large
misunderstandings about swap is actually
intended for
especially being that it has almost
absolutely nothing to do with this
popular misconception of being emergency
memory
or kind of slower ram as some people
believe it is
people also have this really weird idea
when talking about swap that they should
disable swap because disabling it will
somehow magically stop memory contention
from turning into
disk operations um but this is obviously
not true right
just because you can't measure it you
just believe that that's true it it
painly [ __ ] like
if we can't evict anonymous pages which
is what happens if you don't have swap
then we're just gonna thrash the file
cache we're just gonna throw out the
file cache
and even worse we might be able to we
might be forced to reclaim uh
hotter file cache pages than we would
actually want to reclaim
so we even do something less desirable
than what would happen
in terms of disk io if you had swap so
these kind of misunderstandings have
really hobbled swap's reputation and
they've led to this
misconception that it's not useful if
you have a lot of memory or some
[ __ ] like that
so a swap isn't just some mechanism to
expand your ram what is it
well swap allows reclaim on types of
memory which would otherwise
be unlocked that is it provides this
backing store for anonymous memory which
otherwise would be locked into ram it
also allows to
by its slow nature ramp up
memory contention more gradually which
is really important to catch and kill
processes which are affecting the system
rather than just kind of falling over
and dying without swap it's really hard
to run with positive memory pressure
it's really hard to run
hot on memory or in a memory balance
system because we almost
immediately go from you know using all
of the available pages and everything
working hunky dory
to oops you requested one too many pages
now the system is completely falling
over
and we get completely deadlocked this is
because running
running really hard on memory and
running out of memory becomes
really binary without swap it just
happens way
too fast to act on in any reasonable way
another thing is that if you've compiled
things you've probably seen you know
this make
dash j cause plus one stuff well why do
we do that
well we do that because we want to fill
up any of the remaining slack
uh by work appear reappearing or work
going away
uh from increases and decreases in
demand and we want to do this with
memory too we want to always be pushing
it just a little bit
so that we can make the absolute maximal
use of everything that we have
and this comes back to what i mentioned
earlier about us
as the operating system as the lynx
kernel wanting to promote the most
efficient use of memory possible
and we want to do this without impacting
system latency too much so we do need to
be careful in the way we do that
without swap memory contention increases
by comparison are really just very very
sudden
often systems aren't really recoverable
from that state and i'll go into an
example case of that later
that is when we go over the edge you
know we end up just recycling pages so
fast
in and out from disk and into memory
that we can't make real forward progress
anymore
and swap does come with some trade-offs
but in general
it does prevent a lot of these
situations from occurring in the first
place
and if you're generally of the opinion
that swap isn't useful or it's some
relic from the past
i really do recommend reading uh the
post of this link
and uh taking a look at what's contained
i hope it will give you some insights
into how we want to use it
one reason that people particularly
don't like swap as well
is because it can delay invocation of
the own killer the colonel umkiller is
essentially what's invoked when the
system is ostensibly
out of memory and it's essentially a
massive cannon that you
fire at some process and you pray that
you fired it
you know in the right direction and
usually you find it kind of
in the wrong place and these are part of
the two fairly major constraints of the
um killer number one is you know if you
invoke it
you've probably already lost probably
everything on the system now is pretty
much
queued up due to the fact that memory
hotness information and memory access
information is hidden behind the cpu's
memory management unit we don't actually
know as the kernel when we are out of
physical memory
uh in a readily available way this might
come as a surprise
but it is true linux really just has
absolutely no idea when you are out of
memory
it only knows when it tries really
really really hard to
go and get some more memory to go and
free some pages but it couldn't do it
for quite a while
generally this is because only the cpu
propagates
uh this mmu page hit information this
does this pte young stuff
and calculating ourselves will be way
too expensive so we have to proactively
pull this information when we're trying
to free pages that's what reclaim means
so the problem here isn't knowing when
our memory is full we know that
um because our goal is all the time to
have our memory as full as possible
basically
it's easy to know how many pages of
resident what's not so easy is knowing
how many
pages we could easily free if required
and as discussed we don't
really know when we're out of memory
because we need to reclaim first to know
that information which can take a really
really long time it's a very expensive
process potentially involving all kinds
of io
as you'd also imagine we only want to
invoke the um killer when
the we actually are out of memory so
this means there can be a really long
long
time after totally running out of memory
that you wait before you actually get
the um killer invoked so
we already have to go through a lot of
reclaim attempts might have to do a lot
of disc i o we might have to look at the
mmu hotness statistics
uh so relying on the um killer to do
something on your system in a timely
fashion
is really a fool's errand it might
happen to work for you right now but
there's a million other cases in which
it will not work for you
and in which your system will grind to a
halt so our goal in general
should be to avoid having to invoke the
um killer at
all and avoiding memory starvation in
the first place
and i'll come back to how we go about
doing that reliably at scale
in a slide or two's time a second
problem with the um killer is that it's
not really configurable
uh we have this thing called um scores
um i love anything in the kernel called
a score because it means that when we
designed the interface we really had no
[ __ ] clue how it's supposed to be
used
uh in general like nobody knows how this
is supposed to work even the pub
people who work on memory don't know how
this is supposed to work you either set
it to like minus a thousand or like plus
a thumb or i think 999 is probably the
limit
you said it's like the maximum limits or
something or you set it like in the
middle
and you kind of pray that it's higher or
lower or somehow
like somewhere different than some other
application in general nobody knows how
this is supposed to work like
it does play into the um heuristics
about what to kill
but aside from the absolute absolutes of
like minus
whatever um it's really hard to reason
about what that's actually going to make
the unkiller do
and how exactly the um color is going to
behave and whether it's going to have
the desired effect or not
so uh this often means that the oom
killer will just kill the complete wrong
thing on the system it often just kills
the largest thing on the system
uh or kills things until it randomly
kind of finds
the one which was causing the problem um
so obviously not
a great solution to the actual problem
there
so i keep on bringing up this this thing
called called reclaim it's probably
worth
going a little bit into how that works
so reclaim is just a fancy word for this
process of trying to free pages
there are many different ways in which
reclaim could happen two common ways are
this k-swap d reclaim
or direct reclaim k-swap d reclaim is
done by a background kernel thread which
tries to proactively freeze some memory
when we are reaching some threshold for
example if you use 95 percent of memory
or something like that
um casework reclaim avoids going into
this next and scary phase of reclaim
which is called direct reclaim which is
what happens if your application
requests memory but there isn't any
available right now
this can result in your service having
an actually measurable freeze
which obviously sucks because what's
going to happen is we're going to
actually suspend the application from
execution while we go and try and get
some memory
so that's why we have this other
proactive k-swap d kernel thread which
avoids getting into this directory claim
state in the first place
reclaiming some pages may also be easier
or harder than others we talked a little
bit earlier about this reclaimable
memory stuff and what it actually means
some pages may be reclaimable just not
right now for example some cash pages
may be so hot
that it makes no sense to evict them
right now and the applications accessing
those pages would just be driven into
the ground if we try to do so
and the same goes for anonymous pages if
you don't have swap
um if there's no swap free or there's no
swap available then without a backing
store for that memory it's just locked
in memory and you can't
do anything with it which kind of breaks
down memory management because
you simply cannot reclaim a huge class
of pages
some page types may also be reclaimable
right now but it takes some
effort in order to do so for example
dirty pages which are pages in the page
cache which have been modified and are
waiting to be written back to disk
uh need to be flushed to the disk first
before we can actually proceed in
freeing them right
otherwise we'd either lose the
modifications of the file or even
potentially corrupt
the file system or other critical parts
of the the system
in practice this variance and
unpredictability and reclaim means that
it's typically really hard to
tell ahead of time when you're actually
running out of physical memory but if we
wanted to know that
how would we go about it if i were to
ask you to tell me you know
how how would you tell if your machine
was oversubscribed on
memory what kind of metrics would you
traditionally look at well
when i ask this question at conferences
typically the answer i get is something
like
you know look at the free memory but the
problem with looking at free memory
is that it doesn't tell you anything
really because in general we want to use
all of the available memory on the
system as much of the time as possible
so it's going to say it's full almost
all the time
and then usually somebody says you know
okay we'll just subtract the caches and
buffers
from the free memory but again some
caches and buffers might actually be
needed they might not be able to be
reclaimed at
this particular point in time so you
really can't just subtract them and
expect that to make sense
another metric that often some more
senior engineers bring up is um
page scan rate page scan is essentially
the rate at which we are going through
pages trying to reclaim them trying to
free them
and if it's very large it means we are
having to scan a long way through the
memory lists
to try and find some pages to free which
are eligible to be freed
and the problem with page scans is very
hard to differentiate
a very efficient use of the system from
over subscription
on the system so it's not really easy to
tell
just from these metrics whether you're
tipping over the edge or whether you're
in a perfectly steady state
there are other metrics of course we
could spend all day going through them
but
all of them up to this point have their
caveats and limitations and they can all
trigger
under normal operation and and uh you
useful
uh system state as well as actual system
instability and over saturation
so usually all of these metrics which we
come up with are just approximations of
memory pressure so what is
memory pressure well we've never really
had a metric like memory pressure in the
kernel before
we have many related metrics like the
ones we've just been over
but even with all of those metrics it's
really hard to tell you know what is
real pressure and what is just a very
efficient use of the system
for example uh in memory we might want
to be able to tell you know how much of
the time
uh threads on the system being stuck
doing memory work and we have this
this new kernel feature called psi
which for memory for example can tell
you the amount of time the threads on
the system were stuck
doing some kind of non-ideal memory work
like faulting back in pages or doing
some kind of work which
if we had more memory we probably
wouldn't need to do so
the word sum here the line sum here
means some threads in that c group were
stuck doing this non-ideal memory work
for say
0.2 to 1 of the time in the last 10
minutes
and full means the same except for all
threads in the secret were stuck doing
that
this could be things like you know
waiting for a colonel memory lock being
throttled
waiting for reclaim to happen even more
it could be just you know waiting for
dis guy or waiting for things to be
swapped waiting for page cash
uh faulting and stuff like that um so
pressure is essentially saying you know
if i had more of this resource
i probably could run 0.21 faster so it's
quite a useful metric if you're
developing high availability
applications
or high reliability applications and
stuff like that it really gives you an
overview of like
how your system is operating not just uh
at an ideal circumstance but whether
it's being oversubscribed and stuff like
that
for example for the high availability
and high reliability use case we had
facebook use this to know in advance
whether we're about to use too much
memory for
async jobs for background jobs on the
web servers and we do load shedding we
can we can say you know
we couldn't take that much more memory
ahead of time we know when we are
actually reaching memory saturation
using this metric which we don't know
with any of the other metrics
and you can't measure this just by
looking at resident memory because again
you simply don't know what's reclaimable
and what's not ahead of time
these psi metrics are also what powers
our premium detection at facebook and we
do this as part of a project which we've
open source
called umd umd is essentially a user
space um killer with a really
fine-grained policy engine and this
allows you to encode policies of
what to do in certain memory pressure
situations for example
we run chef on our machines as part of
configuration management and while chef
is important if we're running tight on
memory we can live without it for a few
minutes and the same goes for other
background work which isn't customer
facing
umd allows you to encode things like
that based on these pressure metrics for
example
we might be able to measure a best
effort applications pressure metrics
and if the best-selling application
starts to cause contention for others or
calls system-wide contention
we can either kill it before um or
performance degradations happen or
throttle it or do whatever we want
using these metrics we can prevent um
entirely while still preserving system
stability
and avoiding grinding to halt
system-wide and same cannot be said
when the kernel wound killer is used
because again it often results in a
significantly degraded system for long
periods of time
simply because it has to go through so
many reclaimed passes whereas we can
passively monitor it
through system reclaim in general
another thing which you might have seen
me talking about in the old days of
sugary 2 was
limits that's this memory.high and
memory.max stuff and the initial
proposal for segregate 2 was to limit
non-essential work in the machine
kind of a traditional approach but this
has among a few other things a few
major problems one fundamental problem
is that it doesn't treat applications
which have highly variable
resources very well for example if you
have an application which uses 900
megabytes of one second
and 1.5 gigabytes or another second if
you set the value too
low to the low amount then the
application might just get um killed
unnecessarily but if you set it too high
you know the application for the
majority of its lifetime might just have
completely free reign over the system
with no real consequences
so that becomes a bit of a problem just
using limits it doesn't really allow for
any ball parking
another critical problem is that the
resource usage of some system-wide
demons can be very heavily tied to the
core workload on the machine
for example if you have a demon locally
available which does like tier lookup or
service lookup that kind of stuff and it
has a cache
how big that cache gets largely depends
on what it's asked to do by the main
workload if the web server requests
some kinds of tiers which are very large
maybe the cache gets very large
and this is a problem because most fleet
wide service owners for these kind of
demons
don't necessarily know what the
reasonable values for their services
memory should be because it's so
variable depending on what they're asked
to do
so even if they can record it right now
it could change five minutes in the
future when they're requested to do
something else
something that we can reason about
though is how much memory we actually
want to reserve
for the primary workload like the web
server or whatever
so it's much more easily configurable to
make some kind of guarantees
about what we will give the workload
rather than act punitively against other
non-essential services when
maybe we really didn't need to generally
large service owners like
web tier owners do know roughly how much
their service does require because they
know what their user base looks like
they know what their requests look like
and that's something which is a lot more
uniform across the fleet
so for this reason we've largely shifted
to using and improving our protection
tunables that's this memory.min and
memory.low stuff
which define hard and best effort
protection respectively and when you're
below your protection threshold
what happens is we don't reclaim memory
at all from you in the case of
memory.mim we never breach we will never
reclaim from you as long as you're below
your limit and
for memory.low we would only reclaim
from you below your limit if we are
under
system-wide memory contention anyway
this allows significantly more work
conservation allows a lot more work to
happen on the machine
without punishing people unnecessarily
demons can use as much
memory as they like as long as they
don't affect overall system stability
and that's one thing which has been very
helpful
in developing this overall strategy for
resource control
so this is all very well and good i've
gone through a whole lot of primitives
but how do we actually intend to use
them
well this is where fb tax 2 comes in fb
tax 2 is our overall project for
resource control at facebook
see guru v2 is certainly one of the
primary things which we need to achieve
that
however as we've gone over in this talk
we also need a lot of other supporting
elements it to work and be in place to
make it actually
composed to a functional and coherent
system so one concern
of course is stopping background
services that the main workload isn't
dependent on from affecting the workload
for example as we mentioned metric
aggregation or configuration management
going crazy and like stealing memory
from the web server
or running the machine out of memory
entirely
we also want to have reasonable behavior
if we start to exceed the capabilities
of the hardware if we try to use too
much memory
again to scale to our future capacity
needs we do need to have this
high resource density we need to be
having high memory pressure
and making the best use of positive
pressure um so
of course this does come with the risk
of going over the edge pushing it a
little bit too far right
so we need to have graceful behavior
when we do inevitably push it a little
bit too far
it's also really important that our
efforts are kind of lightweight it's no
good if we can now load machines 10 more
if we also take 10 percent of load of
the machine to do it if you get my
point um it's also no good if we
you know produce this very technically
incredible solution but it's such a
burden
on site operation or maintenance or
service operation
that nobody actually wants to use it in
practice so we have to make it usable
and that's one thing we've been very
conscious of when
designing secret v2
so fb tax 2 in general comprises a
really wide range of solutions to
compose to a usable system we do need to
tune the base os and be opinionated
to make sure that it's capable of
isolating resources otherwise
on non-compliant systems we might
actually end up
breaking down and making things worse
than doing nothing at all
as we mentioned earlier we also have the
aforementioned early um killer umd
running on fb tax 2 machines
on those machines it monitors the
threats to the workload and misbehaving
workloads on shared machines
it prevents these very obviously
misbehaving applications from posing a
threat to overall system health based on
the policies which you've assigned
as for how this actually looks at the
base os layer we use battery fs
as the root file system this is needed
because as mentioned we have some fairly
insurmountable priority inversions we
found one of those was in ext4
in the way in which it does journal uh
journaling
where you have to flush out all of the
entries in the journal at once and one
of the problems is then you cannot limit
i o for any application
because all applications become
contingent on it completing
so if you have some low priority
application in the journal and
some high priority application in the
journal the high priority one becomes
contingent on the low priority entries
journal entry
being completely flushed to disk and
because we're throttling that's not
going to happen so
bad things occur and the whole system
slows down
so uh fixing these kind of things wasn't
really possible on the xt4 but it has
been false possible on butter fs
we do have a lot of the butterfly's core
maintainers at facebook obviously not a
coincidence of why we've
been able to do a lot of these things
but in general butterfest's design
is far away from the means of like 10
years ago where you know everyone was
complaining butterflies i ate my data
nowadays we use it on tons and tons of
systems i can't say an exact number but
a lot of systems like a lot of digits of
systems
and it works just fine in fact it
detects a lot of hardware issues which
uh are not detectable due to the way it
does check summing and and stuff like
that
sorry which are not detectable by things
like ext4 so that's one reason people
often complain you know butterfast save
my data and the reason is because no it
actually detects these issues which
other file systems are not detecting
i also mentioned earlier about the
importance of swap usually we might
disable swapping on the main workload it
kind of depends a little bit on what it
does it may or may not be reasonable to
have it enabled for a particular
workload
we do need to swap those system wide to
make sure that we're efficiently able to
reclaim all types of memory and not just
a limited subset
we're also opinionated about some kernel
tunnels one of them is wbt or right back
throttling
if you use desktop linux in the past and
i assume you do since you're at art conf
and most people probably using it on the
desktop
uh you may have encountered the
situation in the bad old days where you
plugged in a usb
drive you tried to copy some files to or
from the usb drive and the whole system
would just
freeze completely the reason for that
is because right back is generally not
stoppable like when you've issued a
right back
everything the forward progress of the
system becomes contingent on right backs
completing
and your whole system is kind of
stalling because like this i o is the
most critical thing it's doing at that
point in time it's a little bit complex
to explain but the general principle is
you cannot slow it down you cannot solve
it so this is what right back throttling
is designed to address
right back has this special property as
we mentioned that due to the way it's
implemented we cannot slow it down or
stop it
so right back throttling is a way of us
avoiding issuing the right back in the
first place
uh and slowing it down if we are
exceeding some threshold or if we know
we're causing the system pain
c groups are also the bread and butter
of resource control so as such it does
make some sense to go into our choices
in terms of configuration there
to get sensible resource control it's
very important to have these clear
definitions of roles from the top level
for example we have system.slice which
is a slice for
uh work which is not time sensitive for
best effort nice to have services which
can be killed or throttled in an
emergency like chef or symmetric
aggregation that kind of stuff we also
have host critical sites which are for
demons which are required by the system
to run
these are typically things that we need
for debugging like ssh logs
also some systemd daemons some d burst
demons that kind of stuff and we want
all these to work even if the system is
generally not having a very good time
we also have workload.slice which is for
the key workloads which are running on
the machine for example hhvm on a web
server or mysql on a database server
and having these really clear
distinctions allows us to
know exactly how we're going to
propagate resources from the top down
based on service role which makes life a
lot easier
this is actually how this used to look
which is punitively limiting the best
effort work
as we mentioned earlier this is fairly
brutal system.slice memory for example
might
legitimately spike and that might be
okay in some circumstances
and we might end up slowing down or
killing things when we really actually
didn't need to the workload didn't need
that
it's also really absolute it doesn't
really allow for any ball parking
if you set a limit a memory limit we're
going to enforce it absolutely we're
going to take some punitive action on
the application if you exceed it
so it's not really great for
applications which have highly variable
resource usage so we need something that
can help with that
and that's why we've changed from using
that to this memory.high
uh from this memory.high and memory and
mac stuff to using protection that's
this memory.low and memory.min stuff
and again these are kind of a guarantee
that we will reserve some memory for
that process
we don't prohibit any other application
from using it but we
aggressively take it away from them if
the workload does end up needing it
and this allows ball parking
significantly more easily because you
can set these kind of thresholds
without affecting overall system
throughput and system stability
you'll also notice the edition of
io.latency this is a new kernel feature
which we've been working on at facebook
but it's available in modern kernels
everywhere use arch linux so you
probably have it
and we didn't really have time to deep
dive into how this works but essentially
it works by
providing disk i o latency threshold
that is you guarantee
some amount of i o completion
responsiveness to the main workload
and some other level to the best effort
and some other to the host critical
services
and it keeps on degrading until it
reaches each of those thresholds
io control is really important when
limiting memory as we've as we've
discussed
and if an application is misbehaving it
can just really cause huge io storms if
you're limited against memory
so this is one reason why we really need
this so having these completion latency
guarantees the right back throttling
and um d really permits stopping these
bad applications from affecting system
stability overall and this happens
before they affect system throughput and
stability at large
i also mentioned i don't want to just
talk about abstract theory i also want
to talk about production success stories
well in this case
we intentionally cause a fast memory
leak in systems.slice on facebook web
servers the best effort slice
don't worry about all of the colors and
lines and little bars yet
we'll go over those essentially the
purple line is without fbt x2 and the
green line is with it
with a normal operating system set up
the crux is basically that
it takes in the order of minutes to
recover from a 10 megabyte a second leak
and this is basically nothing that's
pretty tame compared to a lot of real
life situations
this is another example of why when
people think that the um killer
will come to their rescue it simply
won't
this is all works based on reclaim so
again
if it can make progress if it's making
progress system wide doing reclaim
the system will not invoke the own
killer even though your application
might be being completely dribble and
driven into the ground and only after an
incredibly long time
and sometimes in the order of a double
digit number of minutes
does the system realize it's not
actually making any forward progress
long after you know a fleet wide event
could easily have taken
out your entire service contrast that
with the fb tax 2 case
where we quickly isolate and stop the
leak before it actually affects machine
or workload stability
now we can have significantly better
control over resources and
can not only increase fleet wide
stability but also fleet wide efficiency
which is quite important considering uh
the crunch which i mentioned earlier
in fact we can repeatedly relaunch the
same memory leaking application over and
over and over and has
no effect on the workload whatsoever due
to the fact that umd
is killing it and the fact that we are
throttling it beforehand this is made
possible by all of the primitives which
i've been talking about in this talk
working in tandem no one of them could
do this alone
and this is what i was talking about
when i said we had to build a complete
and compliant
operating system in order to perform
resource control reliably
and none of these can do it by
themselves
on tiers which runs some of the web
background jobs of facebook some of the
primitives mentioned
were even part of permitting them to run
on smaller and more efficient machines
previously they couldn't move because of
so much uncertainty about
the variable memory use of their
workloads but now they can actually use
some of these primitives mentioned
to reliably measure can they take on
more load or should they do load
shedding
which was a huge part of allowing them
to migrate to smaller and more efficient
machines which is another huge win
from these efforts
one thing i'm pretty excited about is
that the new technologies which i
presented in this talk
are allowing us to do things which we
simply never really been able to do
before as engineers
uh or in linux so i really hope that
i've been able to give you some idea
about how these tools and technologies
might be able to help you in your
specific line of work and
i'm really looking forward to seeing
what new novel things
people in this conference might be able
to build
uh using what's presented here in the
coming years
i've been chris down and this has been
linux memory management scale thank you
very much
and have a great day